Speaker 1: All right, I need your help figuring
something out.
Is this a political story or a mental health
story that I am going to be talking about
right now?
And what I mean is pro Trump attorney Lin
Wood, who was involved in trying to overturn
the 2020 election results.
He spoke at some length at an event in South
Carolina on Tuesday and claimed that Donald
Trump is still the president.
Donald Trump is still in control of the military,
could authorize a nuclear first strike by
the military if he wanted to.
So that's where the question comes from.
Is this a political story or is it a mental
health story?
And Linwood simply needs inpatient treatment.
I'm not being facetious.
I'm not playing coy with mental health.
It's just not clear to me what kind of a story
this is.
So let's just jump into the video.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump is
Speaker 3: never conceding that he won the
election.
So it's only good that Trump is the only guy
in the military who will call for the cold
if they need a first strike.
Joe Biden is not going to be the reason
Speaker 2: why can't somebody stop it?
This is driving me crazy.
Speaker 1: So that's already like a treasure
trove of gold.
If the military needed a first strike, they'd
called Trump for the code.
And by that, I assume he means a nuclear first
strike.
The scenario that Linwood is laying out is
the military wants to strike someone with
a nuke.
They go to Joe Biden and say, sir, we need
the codes.
And Biden says, no, we're not launching a
nuke.
So the military says, let's call Trump at
Mar a Lago.
He'll give us the code, sir.
Give us the code.
Biden won't hear it is have it.
Boom, a nuke is launched.
It's a delusional scenario.
I mean, truly.
Let's watch a little bit more of this.
Speaker 2: Well, you got to do something.
Well, you got to remember this man, and I'm
going to tell you
Speaker 3: what I think is a smart idea here
to fix this election in a month.
Right.
But we would have gone way back into the same
swamp and the same mess and nothing would
have really been fixed.
So remember, this isn't about Trump, is it?
About the flesh?
This is about God.
This is about powers and principalities.
God is getting ready to play out this role.
He's got a lot of playing time to do in America.
So we don't want Trump to come back here because
some things are going to have to happen.
He's going to enjoy the best of that as well.
And I like this.
Biden demonstrations back again, Trump's watch
that Trump is watching.
Speaker 1: So now he puts out this other idea.
We could have overturned the election with
the results in one month.
But then if Trump came back in, it would have
been more swamp because we haven't fixed the
swamp yet.
This isn't about Trump, it's about these other
things.
So Trump will come back in time when it makes
more sense for Donald Trump to be back.
But for now, Trump is watching and he's ready
to do the military strike because he still
controls the nuclear codes.
Those are some big claims being made and none
of them have even the slightest connection
to reality.
Let's listen to the last bit here, which might
be the craziest part of all of it.
Speaker 3: I believe my own personal will,
the Insurrection Act.
Everybody knows he's not going to tell anybody.
I think the military is prepared to act if
we have a foreign threat or an internal threat,
that it can't be handled by the police and
the National Guard.
And we're going to allow that to be what appears
to be a large military government, I believe
about some things where you learn about what
you're good about if you've really gotten
because he's claiming things.
Speaker 1: So I know it's tough to hear Linwood
because of all the constant coughing in the
room.
My guess is that's maybe a not heavily vaccinated
crowd.
But he said there he thinks that Trump actually
signed the Insurrection Act in private.
And the military knows that Donald Trump still
is actually in control of the military, which
is out of this world bonkers.
I mean, just completely divorced from any
even possible reality.
And seriously, this stuff has an impact.
It's not just Lynwood.
People believe this stuff.
There are right now, or at least a couple
of days ago, there were people walking around
filling plastic shopping bags with liquid
gasoline.
And those some of those same people refused
to take a vaccine that is safe and can end
the pandemic.
Of course, there are people who hear this
and they believe it and they act accordingly.
Um, and, you know, the the incredible kind
of it's not really a it's a conflict, I guess
I would call it is that on the one hand, if
you ask these folks, how do you feel about
what Joe Biden is doing while in office, they'll
say it's terrible.
Joe Biden is doing all of these horrible things.
But then at the same time, some of them still
believe that Donald Trump is really in power,
pulling all the strings and controlling everything
so well.
So how is Joe Biden even able to do anything
if Donald Trump is actually still in power?
Don't even try.
It will merely be an exercise in frustration